Alright, what can I say.
The greatest thrill of my life is
standing behind that microphone
with you guys behind me.
Let's do it.
I'm in the middle
of a forty-five year conversation
with these men and women
I'm surrounded by.
I started playing the guitar because
I was looking for someone to correspond with.
And after all this time,
I still feel that need to talk to you.
All right, E Streeters!
Let's do this thing.
♪♪
Our years of playing together
have created an efficiency in the studio.
♪♪
Ideas tumble around the room.
Confusion often reigns.
Do you want me to play it up higher?
No, don't play it up higher,
just don't play so low.
And then suddenly...
Let's get the claps.
We'll get the la da da's.
Dynamite.
♪♪
Perfect!
Age brings perspective.
♪♪
And after all these years,
my friends, wherever you are,
♪♪
you are the reason we're here.